[Music]
i'm wwe superstar big e and i'm wwe
superstar goldberg and we're on this
week's
episode of truth or damn
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special we give
our guests two simple options tell the
truth or suffer the wrath of the last
dab and today i'm very excited to
welcome wwe superstars goldberg and big
e both of which you can now rumble with
in the brand new wwe 2k 22 video game
guys the rules are simple i'll ask you a
question when i ask you a question you
have a choice answer it honestly or
escape the truth by eating a deathwing
in big e we're going to start with you
wrestlemania season it's just around the
corner you've had so many iconic
entrances at the showcase of the
immortals from wale playing your walkout
song to final fantasy cosplay to jumping
out of a giant box of budios which one
of those entrances would you say was
your favorite which of those would you
redo if you could oh uh
i gotta go with wale uh that's my guy
the giant box of budios is pretty cool
that's up there too i wish the box was
even bigger that's how we do it yeah
just even bigger all right goldberg
we're gonna switch the attention to you
you're the only man to be named wcw
champion wwe world heavyweight champion
and wwe universal champion which of
those titles are you the most proud of i
would have to say the uh the universal
champion i think it has a lot to do with
my son being in attendance to have my
family there it meant everything in the
world to me well ball said and look at
this round getting through clean no
wings off the board yet maybe we'll turn
up the heat here though in round number
two
biggie we're back with you your tag team
the new day you guys have had a hall of
fame career but i'm curious how you
would rank yourself against your tag
team partners xavier woods and kofi
kingston in an individual matchup yeah
you you know i you know i can't do that
yeah we're gonna we're gonna do this
yeah you know wherever you go all the
wings are outrageously spicy
a little kick
not too bad
[Applause]
very strong biggie no cell right
i keep waiting for it to ramp up if it
stays here i'm good
that's not that bad actually i ain't
going
all right get my car keep eating it
y'all
goldberg perhaps it's time to join the
party from interviewing wrestlers in the
past i know the pre-fight rituals the
stuff of locker room legend is there a
wrestler who annoyed you the most behind
the scenes even if you respected what
they brought to the ring oh yeah how
much time do i
[Music]
i'd say scott hall may be at the top of
that list
100 as much as i'd like to eat these
wings i'd much rather
i'd
[Music]
you good i'm good it is a lot like
wrestling like hot sauce it's like the
second you start showboating that's when
the sauce comes and hits you over the
head with the chair
i got a little air green
[Music]
here we are in the third round and we're
gonna do things a little bit differently
here all right biggie on your podcast
the new day feel the power you said that
your ideal opponent your dream opponent
would be goldberg you talked about
meeting him when you were younger at a
signing in tampa and later went on to
say that if you faced each other you'd
put them down like old yeller so now
what i'd like to do is everybody grab a
wing and i'd like you guys to get face
to face and talk about how things would
really go down if you met in the ring
well
bill
there was a time
where i looked up to you you still
freaking look up to me
it's a height joke i've had many short
jokes all my life it's not new to me my
thing is just be careful what you wish
for i'm in my physical prime mm-hmm
and at 55 years old i can still put you
down
because my physical prime
is 90 better than 100 of everyone else i
don't that's too much math for us to be
doing right now i know d lyman's really
don't do a lot of math i'm talking about
a mess but you know why don't we do this
i would love for nothing more than that
to happen right here
right now let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who's next i'm next go pick up or
download wwe 2k22 today
[Music]
boy that that was a tiny bit it was a
tiny bit spicy i like how you took our
attention away from the wings yeah are
you feeling it now huh oh yeah i'm
feeling i'm look at me i sweat standing
in the back and everybody makes fun of
me as i'm walking to the ring because
i'm in a full sweat people don't
understand that i pour a bottle of water
on my head this is not water